we have a voicemail number that number
is 219
to david p we haven't heard from the
eggman for a while
he is furious that i indicated yesterday
that apple pie is not very good take a
listen
hi dave um there's been a couple things
i've disagreed with you maybe like hate
crime enhancements
and the death penalty and i've actually
been one over on almost both of those
almost totally by you
but dave saying apple pie is junk is
just ridiculous
it's really the only good pie it's
actually the only sweet
pie unless unless you consider chocolate
cream pie an actual pie which it's not
so you got what berries and what kind
what do you put in your pie
if it's not apple this is sad i can't
get on board with that you're disgusting
for saying apple pie is not good
so um i mean listen i'm glad to
entertain any serious conversation
but you know entertaining the idea that
that pie is good or particular apple pie
is good
if you want to talk about serious
serious desserts if you want to come to
me and talk about flan
if you want to have a serious
adjudication of tiramisu chocolate
bobcat
pistachio baklava you know a sort of
molten
warm chocolate chocolate cake uh
we will do that on this program but you
know starting to platform the idea that
apple pie is good i'm just not gonna do
it and what you're gonna write to me
i you're gonna write to me and tell me
oh you heat it up and then you put
vanilla ice cream on it get the hell out
of here
we're not this is not the show for that
there are plenty of shows out there i'm
sure
couldn't tell you which ones they are
where if you're looking for pi
apologia you can find it but not on this
program
we've got a great bonus show for you i
won't even tell you what's on it just
trust me
it's a good one get instant access by
becoming a member
at joinpakman.com